hello
this is my first trip first time in life
i'm outside of the walls of gaza i'm so
happy to be here
my ambition always was to be a pilot
to fly plane to feel free
to fly the sky to touch the sky
but that didn't happen simply i live in
gaza
there is no airport
all borders are closed on every side
we live in one of the biggest prison in
the world
the only thing i can do just to look
up to the sky on some days
we are lucky we have electricity for
four or five
hours when it's cold we make a fire
on the front or on the roof of our homes
sometimes we make food too my job in
gaza is to arrange everything to
journalists who come to my homeland
to tell stories about what's going on in
gaza
many morning i had to go to the border
area to collect a journalist
if anything should happen to the
journalists
or if the journalists decide to cover a
story
the government doesn't want us to cover
bad things could happen
navigating through my country helping
journalists
filmmakers news crews is my working life
i believe my success comes from building
a relationship not only with journalists
and
news crews but also with the communities
in the gaza strip
these communities who don't want their
stores to be told
i never look to them as stories or
numbers
but like like me they are human being
i have built up many relationship over
10 years and guess what
this gives me the chance to get access
to people
to stories others can't in some certain
situation
i feel as a woman i have more power
many male journalists in my society they
want to cover a story
about drug addiction in my country
that problem start the gaza tunnel were
being built
with the siege on gaza tunnels were
brought people
all the basic needs like food building
material other stuff we needed
but not anymore because the egyptian
side fleeted them up with water and they
are not working anymore
drugs were being smuggled and many
young people get addicted to
in the traditional of the palestinian
society it's forbidden for men to enter
the household
so no male journalist get the story
but i did
i have a wonderful husband a wonderful
husband who supports me
despite all the criticism he gets from
the society
he's at home now with my two kids and i
have another one is groaning here
when i'm working i call him each two
hours
and he knows if he doesn't hear from me
from me
he should call my contact the one who
gave me the access to the story
which the one who i trust
one of the times in gaza during the
kidnap
of the british journalist allen johnston
i was asked by an american magazine
to set up a meeting with the kidnappers
in gaza
and i did the journalist covering the
story and i
were asked to meet outside of his hotel
they came they pick up in a black van
with a black window they were wearing
masks in that day
and they drove us away
far away in the middle of a field they
took our cell phones
and we did the interview with the
kidnapper outside in that field
i was so scared that day a day i will
never
forget so
why i do what i do i do it because i
believe
if i didn't a huge part of the story
about
gaza will be missing there are some
more stories i could tell you about my
country
and not all of them they are bad i love
my country
despite the terrible situation we live
in
siege poverty unemployment
but there is life there is people
who are dreamers and amazing people full
of energy
we have a wonderful music and the great
music is cool
we have parkour dancers who dance in the
rubble of their homes
and gaza is the only place in the arab
world where muslim
and the christian live in a strong
brotherhood
during the time of war the hardest part
for me is leaving the house early in the
morning
leaving my children i get used to take a
picture for them
every day because i never know if i will
make it back for them
being a fixer and a journalist is
difficult
and dangerous in gaza but when i hear
the sound of the shilling or the sound
of the bombing
i just head straight towards because
i want to be there first because
these stories should be told
when my children were small and we hear
the sound of the war
i get used to tell them they wear a
fireworks
now they are older they understand
i do have a terrible nightmares
because of all what i witnessed during
war time especially these lifeless
bodies of young
children i still remember a little girl
her name is hala she's the only survivor
from her family
her picture will be with me forever
i will never forget her
i'm proud that i can stand here and
being here today with you
i'm proud that i can tell you
stories sad and happy
stories about my small corner of the
world gaza
i'm proud that i am the first female
fixer working
in gaza and the funny thing they call me
mr rambo
in gaza
i hope one day i will get the chance to
tell the stories of
all other women all other amazing women
i know in my country
i hope that one day i can help other
women
in my country to be fixers like me and
of course sometimes
i feel i can't do this work anymore it's
just
too much for me but i remember these
words
don't limit your challenge but challenge
your limit
don't allow others to stand on front of
your dreams
thank you